plumes of smoke over the Skies of
Sudan's capital Khartoum a daily scene
since fighting began between Sudan's
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces or rsf one month ago
the rsf are using civilians as human
Shields they use people's homes for
protection we consider this a cowardly
way of war the Sudanese Army is now on
the ground you want to fight them fight
them on the ground not from people's
homes
on Monday an airstrike hit a hospital in
East Nile the Army says the rsf has been
using it as a base for military
operations the rsf accused the army of
killing and wounding civilians in the
attack more than 500 people have died
since the start of the fighting
more than 700 000 people have been
forced to move elsewhere within the
country since the start of the conflict
and at least 200 000 have fled to
neighboring countries but Millions
remain in the capital where most of the
fighting is taking place
it started with gunfire and bullets
flying overhead then our home was hit
and we moved to a place that was safe
but it's not safe now there are air
strikes shrapnel flying when there's
fighting we want to leave but we can't
damaged many important facilities they
include the main International Airport
which was the focus of heavy battles
during the first days of the fighting
other facilities such as water and power
plants have also been destroyed by the
fighting with many residential areas cut
off from power and running water for a
month now the struggle between the two
sides has also affected access to
hospitals and markets Food Supplies in
the capital are running low and their
concerns that the situation will
deteriorate further as the fighting
enters its second month
other cities in Sudan have also
witnessed fighting the most recent is
Janina in West Darfur where militias
Allied to the rsf have been attacking
the city for four days
we call on all the international
organizations and the U.N agencies to
provide safety and food and to protect
civilians we also ask for the return of
Health Services because the situation
here in Janina is a catastrophe all
International organizations and civil
societies should direct their assistance
to Janina
Army and the rapid support forces on
Friday signed what they called a
humanitarian declaration in Jeddah in
Saudi Arabia it aims to allow those
trapped in hartum to leave conflict
areas and for Aid to come in to those in
need as well as protecting people and
their homes but that's yet to happen on
the ground where the fighting is
continuing along with the destruction
and deaths and wounding of civilians
Khartoum
feising has broken out in Senegal